oh this is funny Chris Wilding was once
on Canadian Match Game did you know that
when he was younger yeah no I didn't
know that I got the tape of it and our
second contestant grew up watching great
game shows with his grandma she's here
in the audience tonight
[Applause]
we're all friends let's play some
[Music]
math game shows with your grandma all
the time yeah Darren I grew up with my
grandma in the house and she always had
the game show channel on so I've seen
the same old woman win the same old
couch about a thousand times ah it's uh
that's great you know you can bet money
on it because she's old and forgetting
yeah she thinks she's actually uh
watching the show from home right now
she's in the audience
she's 90.
wow Chris you were killing as a
contestant I mean you were you were
really doing well on there by the way
imagine you guys found that that's crazy
it was like how'd you do a match game
how old were you doing good I won um
this would have been I was probably I
don't know 26. wow because in a weird
way like I won you know on a Canadian
game show you don't win much money I
think I won maybe 5 000 Canadian which
is like maybe 3 000 U.S I I went to the
top I won and my final match was with
Scott Thompson of kids in the hall and
it was black blank what would you put
for that
now I put Jack and he put jack so I won
like yeah I think it was like 4 500
bucks or something I won